so so back to the original point as to
why we're talking about you know being
lazy
is that you mentioned these 55 year old
guys have essentially become lazy
like getting i i could imagine when yes
i think so how old is bill maher
oh there's nothing dude they're plugging
in they're plugging in words to a
formula that they've said before a lot
of ways
let's see how old this guy is yeah we
have to look it up now bill maher is 64
years old he's not even 55 he's 64.
i would imagine a totally drumming team
it was a week after the covington kids
incident and he was wrong and i'm like
dude your show is alive how hard is it
to use google
all of these news outlets and eventually
issued these like
you know half-assed corrections and he
was still wrong and i'm like
that is low information laziness
yeah and that's where people like seth
macfarlane and
and bill maher are and seth macfarlane i
don't think it's his obligation to be on
the pulse because he made a cartoon show
about
you know fart humor but bill maher is
literally doing political commentary and
comedy he's a comedian
and it's like he's just gotten so lazy
with it that it's like two months after
something happens
he talks about it you know like like
woke culture and castle culture it's
like
i'm glad you're calling out this
authoritarianism and this weird pc
culture
but dude you're talking about stuff
that's months old like you didn't just
realize
did you not google anything well there's
an ecosystem right and
unfortunately how it works is people
like you i guess would be like a rung
under that
and what they do is they look at you
guys and it's like oh when it works for
the underrung underneath them
and then there's an ecosystem that goes
below right but there's an
all of the you'll watch the same thing
with dave chappelle or
like you know people like that watch
what like the comics that are like the
kind of top young people in the clubs
are talking about
two years later that'll be like
chappelle's special and it's like
there's
unfortunately like you know eventually
you get to have that position and then
you can kind of be like
what's going on down there oh okay i'll
do that i'll pluck
i'll talk about that because maybe
you're not in the clubs you're not in
the mix you're not
you're talking to the people right so
it's you know that's why someone like
joe rogan's
he's kind of like older but he's still
super relevant because he's still in it
right he's still having guests on he's
still reading all the news
he's in it maybe the reality is there's
some political commentators that are
like high profile and on tv for a long
time
that i think probably should have
retired a long time ago and they're
phoning it in
they're like salaries good the ratings
are good just you write it up i'll read
it and then i'm going home
i think howard stern still has another
20 seasons in him he thinks i don't i
think
how many does he get does anybody even
listen to that guy anymore all he does
is bring people on
dude he's like in my fa like one of my
favorites of all time but all he does
now is bring
ex-cast members of snl on and ask them
about their audition for an hour and a
half are you serious
but basically so he i know that he's
like been vocal recently
and i'm like who does he who does he
talk to do people actually listen
yeah a lot of people like that that's
the other thing it's
you know to be controversial or
you know it's kind of a young man's game
in a lot of ways right so when you're
60 years old or 70 years old do you
really want everyone yelling at you and
all that stuff you're like
but again and then there is something to
be said about that when you're on that
age like maybe just step outside and do
a david letterman style maybe you don't
have to insert yourself but like
to kind of insert yourself and then to
take the easy take it's like someone
like howard stern and that's where the
sasha baron cohen's and stern it's like
they kind of go
they take the side of you know what
mainstream culture is and it was like
everything that you're saying right now
would have made anything that you've
done your entire career
you know not available to do like sesame
corn kind of went on
you know all these news outlets and he
was doing like a speech for the adl and
he's goes
you know we need to stop any semitism
and all this stuff and facebook and
everybody okay but
sesame cohen had a song called uh throw
the jew down a well right
wow satirical mind you but if you were
to put that on facebook right now if
ryan long me a new video that's coming
out one of my monday videos
and it's throw the jew down a well and
it's a bunch of people singing that it
would be taken down in one second
yeah so it's kind of like there's this
hypocrisy he's like well yeah
those rules don't apply to you now and
it's they always want to kind of you
know pull the rug out for people behind
them and i think
a lot of people i just don't think they
even see the hypocrisy you know that he
did get censored on facebook though
sasha baron cohen for what one he had he
had some article about hate speech
and the image he used was a was a
picture of so no it wasn't his speech
was fake
fake news he was like this
disinformation is making people go crazy
or whatever and we got to fix it
and the image he used was someone
holding like a q anon sign and so
facebook flagged it as false
and then he was like showing the thing
but then he tweeted he was like facebook
what are you doing why are you censoring
me
i'm special i'm a good one yeah exactly
dude and he's like one of the funniest
guys that ever lived like
like so dude your early alley well
you could i mean again like i really do
think this kind of like edgy boy comedy
stuff is like a young man's game if you
really want to
so i i think you can wear you can't be
in hollywood hobnobbing with these
people and then also be making crazy you
can't be a pc edgy boy
well i know i agree so it's like he's
trying to be
because these people don't have
principles sasha baron cohen should be
the one
mocking the authoritarian ivory tower
elites
he was supposed to be but he's one of
them now so how
he's making these movies you know he's
married he's in the club he has to see
and i get it like even as a
comedian it's like if i was in living in
la and then i go
and see all these people and i was doing
my podcast i would be like you know what
this guy and i go hey
i kind of spent an hour talking to that
guy yesterday like i just feel kind of
like what am i that guy it just so i
just go for it now the trick is you have
to do what south park guys do you have
to kind of stay out of it
as soon as you stay as soon as you get
it as soon as it's all your friends
now you're just doing what politicians
do where you have to go out and pretend
and then you meet them again you go you
know
this is all just an act but it's hard to
be real and be truthful
when these are your friends like imagine
you do that like could you go and do a
full episode about why he's a piece of
garbage and then be like
hey buddy ian punted a cat i'd be like
dude this guy paunted a cat yeah
what are you doing he would rat you out
that quick
yeah we argue on the show quite a bit
well that's that's one we're friends you
know but like
you know it's it's fun to argue things
when we do but i mean that's why one
i like comedians a little bit you you'll
see comedians a lot of times say you
know
we have like a code i won't make fun of
comedians and one of the reasons is
because you have to see them every day
you know it's like you how do you go
make fun of someone and then show up at
work and they're there
and you've started a whole internet
campaign you'd be like yo what the hell
dude
i i i agree it's a fight about like me
personally
i'd be like i'm gonna say whatever i
want you know i mean like if if someone
does something that's worthy of me
being made fun of i'd be like dude
you're a comedian i'm a comedian grow up
yeah but see the difference is that tim
is not pulling up the ladder behind him
and what i see a lot of these comedians
doing is just
reeling up the ladder behind them they
don't care about who comes next they
don't care about who's
next online like they they really they
don't care
like i don't understand why not they
should care about the next generation
joe rogan does yeah and i think that
there is
you can look at it two ways you can be
you can say these people
are kind of evil or you can say it's
like naive or you know they just don't
even see
care or see any of it right but i think
it's probably the latter it's like
this is just what's around them they go
hey if you do this you're one of the
good guys and then you go also it does
kind of screw over people but you don't
even see it like that you kind of
one of the things that kind of drove me
nuts is there some people that were you
know whether they're comedians or they
go
there's this new thing where eve it's
almost like they're trying to extend an
olive branch
against cancer culture where they go you
know we need to make a path for
redemption
and i get the message sounds good where
you go there needs to be a path for
redemption
for people that have you know said the
wrong things or
done the wrong things and everyone goes
yeah see this is how we need to treat
people but
and it's core it seems nice but you go
who made you judge and jury
for what are the right opinions and it's
just inclu like a lot of their premises
are just included
that they have all of the right opinions
and takes and you know lifestyle
uh things and then and you're wrong and
you go
or or option two is maybe we're allowed
to have different opinions
and i don't need to be uh put in the
corner of the bad guys
and then you allow me to come in like
that's church language you know now
parlor is taking off
yeah parlor's taken off and
conservatives are joining like crazy and
it's really funny when i see these these
leftists and liberals making fun of it
i'll see them on facebook all the time
and they'll say like you know uh what do
they call it mind space
you know that sounds a little german
yeah
and it was like it's like
and uh they're all like you know it's
where all the racists are someone posted
i would go to parlor but i think i've
had my fill of hearing racist spout the
n-word
and i'm like you actually you actually
can't say that on parlor parlor's got
broadcast uh restrictions they say it's
like if you can't say it on tv you can't
say it on parlor
so it's actually fairly strict that
people are just
hoping that they're not going to be
biased against them so like on
on twitter you get banned for saying
learn to code you can say learn to code
on parlor
on twitter you can actually say some
fairly offensive things and not get
banned that you can't say on parlor
but people it's just different rules
yeah and and
partisan rules i mean you know this is
the problem in general with
you know entertainment and all sorts of
things
is that you know the free speech becomes
like a right-wing thing so there's these
left-wing
you know networks and stuff like that so
the right-wing networks go oh we'll be
like the free speech network but it's
like no you're not
parlor is like a bunch of right-wing
creators that were like it's pretty
pretty vocal about their opinions right
what you need is like bipartisan like i
want to go
when i talk to these tv networks that
are you know you look at their thing and
it's all trump's the worst and i'm not
really interested in being part of that
but then you know you go to these other
places and they're like we agree you can
say whatever you want but like
nothing bad about jesus and also trump
kind of rules okay
what you want is a tv network that says
i don't even know what these guys are
doing but the kids seem to like it like
that's what you
want them to not be involved they go i
don't have a political opinion
this is what it you know and there's a
bit of that at these streaming services
but
that's what you need a twitter that is
started by someone that says
hey i also don't have a big parlor
account i'm not trying to like build my
profile in conjunction with this new
platform
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you